ceci dit pour les sanctions qui sont sur
le point d'être adopté ce soir pour
l'union européenne vu qu'elles n'ont
toujours pas été précisée même si on a
quand même des indications assez forte
ce soir on est sur une application
immédiate parce qu'on est sur des
mesures de gel des avoirs principalement
et les mesures de gel des avoirs elle
est imposée effectivement pour répondre
à votre question directement aux
entreprises qui peuvent avoir des liens
commerciaux avec
différentes sociétés russes qui sont
détenues par ces nouveaux ces nouvelles
personnes sanctionnées à prendre des
mesures immédiatement par contre ce qui
est assez intéressant et je rebondis
tout à fait sûr que vous disiez la
russie se prépare en 2014 la russie
avait un peu pris de court ça fait huit
ans maintenant que ces sanctions
existent quasiment peu ou prou vu que
les toutes premières ont été adoptées en
mars 2014 la russie se prépare la russie
a rapatrié ces capitaux la russie a
imposé à ses banques de sortir ses
avoirs qui étaient détenus par des
banques étrangères et de les ramener
dans le temps dans le territoire russe
ah oui c'est tourner également vers la
chine enverra deux manières énergétique
donc d'une certaine manière les
sanctions même si elles sont
d'application immédiate même si elle
impose un peu de travail pour les
entreprises sont actives en russie elles
n'auront pas forcément des faits
immédiatement pour répondre à votre
question sur la temporalité